[Music]  demi lovato breaks her silence following  her apparent overdose last month the  sober singer took to Instagram with a  heartfelt message about her journey with  addiction admitting that it's something  she must quote continue to overcome Demi  went on to thank God for keeping her  alive and well as well as her family  team fans and the staff at cedars-sinai  hospital in Los Angeles reading quote  without them I wouldn't be here writing  this letter to all of you I wanna be a  role model  the 25 year old concluded her message  writing I look forward to the day where  I can say I came out on the other side I  will keep fighting  a source told et last week that Demi is  doing much better and is expected to  leave the hospital soon and according to  a second source Demi is planning to  check into a rehab system that works for  her once she's released her Brahmas so  get help  it wasn't my intention